manuel cortez ist so zugeschaltet den
kennen wir aus in aller freundschaft
oder verliebt in berlin also ein
bekannter schauspieler der aber jetzt
den zeitz depp gemacht hat und ist
berater für firmen aber auch für
privatleute hallo herr cortez ja hallo
dann toll dass sie dabei sind also sind
offenbar auf der autobahn irgendwo ich
hoffe die verbindung hält mit krisen
kennen sie sich womöglich aus damit
haben sie er fällt auch schon mal selbst
erfahrungen gemacht oder auch jetzt
gerade wegen corona haben viele leute
auch angst um ihr geld wie sieht es da
mit den schauspielern aus na ja also ich
meinen krisen sind schauspieler relativ
gewöhnen weil nicht so sehen denn die
meisten es ist natürlich so die lage
macht letztlich unbedingt gerade besser
aber sag ich mal so sicherheit ist etwas
was man ja schauspielerei nie wirklich
hat das sind können die meisten
wahrscheinlich mit diesem gefühl relativ
gut umgehen
aber natürlich haben gerade künstler
gerade freiberufler in dieser krise
besonders große schwierigkeiten weiß
auch wenig wage ich mal möglichkeiten
gibt das aufzufangen
gibt es denn da so ein tipp den sie
haben für leute die vielleicht
verzweifelt sind die vielleicht auch
sogar angst haben jetzt vor der zukunft
ja aber erst mal klingt blöd nur
abklatschen aber angst ist
grundsätzlicher schlechteste ratgeber
die man haben kann und man kann krisen
durch das richtige meint fällt auch
immer wieder als eine große chance sehen
das klingt immer noch ein bisschen leer
und verlieren aber es ist nicht wirklich
aber in mainz es ist das entscheidende
goal was man haben kann man kann so
viele dinge auf einer krise heraus die
man kann sehen auch im unternehmens ist
mein unternehmen krise sicher wenn nein
warum was haben wir in der vergangenheit
fast zu tun was kann ich jetzt in der
aktuellen lage tun um meine lage zu
verbessern kann ich etwas sehr tiefes
umsetzen kann ich flexibel sein dass ich
etwas was man nur empfehlen kann also
aus der letzter gegner angst heraus zu
kommen und sich in das produkt
schaffen zu begeben weil dadurch kann
man an krisen batzen egal ob das ist im
privaten im familiären oder im
geschäftlichen sinne ist lang ist der
schlechteste ratgeber die man haben kann
bleiben wir doch mal mit den
schauspielern oder menschen die jetzt
gerade an sich verzweifelt ich denke
auch einige zuschauer sind vielleicht
keine schauspieler aber sind vielleicht
selbstständige solo unternehmer
das sagt sich immer so ganz sei aber wie
kann ich jetzt wenn ich in meinem alltag
so verhaftet bin was sollte ich denn da
was wären denn da so steps soll ich auf
meinen bauch hören oder soll ich auf
freunde hören oder auf sie man kann
vieles tun dann hat gott also wenn man
gut aufgestellt ist hat mir ermöglicht
einen kreis an menschen um sich dem mann
vertraut immer noch mal sprechen kann
das wichtigste ist wird auch die
kommunikation also das gefühl dass man
nicht alleine ist
es geht ein gerade so ist sich dass man
aus eigener blödheit oder unvermögen in
dieser situation gerutscht ist sondern
das ist bei jedem so alleine das mal so
verinnerlicht und zu klären
das ist nicht mein unvermögen das ist
eine weltkrise das sind ein bisschen
druck von einem selber natürlich auch zu
sagen okay wenn ich alleine nicht
schaffen wenn ich zu viel in meinen
angst chaos fällen in gedanken kauf
seien gefangen sind
man kann sich hilfe holen einfach mal
ein online coaching machen einfach mal
mit einem guten freund sprechen einfach
mal aus der blase raus treten und sagen
es liegt immer an mir was ich tue wenn
ich merke als freiberufler der auf seine
eigene arbeit angewiesen ist es komme da
nicht weiter was kann ich tun
immer flexibel bleiben in der
flexibilität nicht immer die veränderung
ist klingt doof ist aber leider gottes
genau so erzählen sie doch mal von von
sich in welcher krise waren sie schon
und wie haben sie es dann letztlich
bewältigt ich mag eigentlich immer ich
fange schon damit an dass ich das wort
krise gar nicht benutzt das hieße
manifestiert sich das in mir dass das
eine ausweglose situation ist ich bin in
einer situation und ob das die krise für
mich ist oder nicht entscheidet immer
noch mein mindset natürlich ist es eine
herausforderung sein und ich muss auch
hier am main verstand meine fähigkeiten
um
mehr unter beweis stellten aber
natürlich ist man gerade als
freiberuflich mal seit über 20 jahren in
künstlerischen und nicht künstlerischen
bereichen fähiges gewohnt 6 diesel
agieren zu müssen
und wenn ich merke ich bin in einer
herausfordernden zeit dann weiß ich umso
mehr
jetzt ist man trennen gefragt und naja
das selbstvertrauen zu entwickeln auch
im deutschen krieges zu meistern lässt
einen sehr erwachsen und kann wirklich
hilfreich sein sondern zeigt auch was
durch durch durchgehen sie sind ja auch
speaker und vermutlich da gut gebucht
wie geht es denn somit zu seminaren
weiter wann können sie da wieder
durchstarten wann verdienen sie am ende
wieder was ja ich meine situation ich
hatte bis ende des jahres hatte ich
viele viele buchungen auftritte von
großen veranstaltungen und diese
natürlich auch alle weggebrochen
und anstatt mich da ist lange zu ärgern
habe ich halt gleich versucht was neues
zu kreieren und wenn als vielmehr den
online bereich gegangen also auch wie
wir heute hier online miteinander
sprechen so haben wir heute durch die
technik und die möglichkeit dinge anders
zu machen also online seminar entwickelt
geschrieben life fonds gemacht um mich
einfach auch zu beschäftigen und neues
zu kreieren und daraus sind jetzt schon
kooperationen entstanden andere spieler
die sie als plattform zusammentun
ideenaustausch das meine ich mit der
flexibilität ich weiß nicht was die
zukunft bringen aber ich glaube die
illusion abzulegen das in zukunft etwas
planbare und vor allem sicheres ist es
glaube ich eine sehr heilsam ergänzt
manuel cortez letzte frage von mir wie
geht es denn so stimmungsmäßig der
branche sind da viele kollegen so drauf
wie sie und nehmen das als chance zur
veränderung oder ist ja auch eine menge
frust dabei dabei der trost ist generell
dar
ob man meine branche nehmen ob man egal
ob man die gesellschaft nimmt aber es
gibt solche und solche
das ist ganz so wie mit jedem menschen
auch nicht es gibt menschen die sagen
jetzt erst recht und da lasse ich mich
nicht unterkriegen und jetzt kriegen wir
schon hin war auch gespräche klar
vermehrt auch mit meinen da menschen
dieser hilfe suchen
bei meinen klienten wird und oft so die
frage was können wir tun die suchen sich
hilfe das miteinander sprechen aber der
ton und das was ich am meisten raus der
ist eigentlich dass viele menschen diese
zeit nutzen um alte strukturen zu
überdenken und auch vielleicht nicht
neue wege zu finden ansatz weiter firma
ja das sind gute ein gutes schlusswort
vielen dank herr cordes weiterhin gute
fahrt auf der autobahn toll dass sie bei
uns in der sendung waren